madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
membres du gouvernement mesdames et
messieurs les députés mes chers
collègues
horreur
sidération
angoisse le monde est aujourd'hui en
état de choc devant la violence de
l'attaque terroriste qui a frappé
Israël devant cette
barbarie je veux redire ici qu'Israël
est un pays ami à qui je veux réaffirmer
au nom de la représentation
nationale notre totale solidarité et
notre soutien
[Applaudissements]
inconditionnel
à
l'heure à l'heure où nous parlons les
combats se poursuivent et le nombre des
victimes ne cesse de
s'alourdir nous pleurons également la
mort de quatre de nos compatriotes et
sommes toujours sans nouvelle de 13
d'entre eux rien ne justifie ni ne
justifiera jamais le
terrorisme aucune cause n'autorise à
tirer sur des civils à enlever des
enfants à utiliser des otages comme
bouclier humain partout sous toutes ses
formes et sous tous ces prétextes le
terrorisme doit être condamné et
combattu sans ambiguité et sans la
moindre nuance attenter à un pays c'est
attaquer toutes les démocraties du monde
attenter aux populations civiles c'est
menacer l'humanité
entière en hommage aux victimes en signe
de solidarité avec leurs familles comme
avec celles qui sont sans nouvelle de
personnes prises en otage porté disparu
je vous demande mesdames et messieurs
les membres du gouvernement mesdames et
messieurs les députés de bien vouloir
observer une minute de
silence
je vous
remerci la parole est à madame la
Première
ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les
députés à mon tour madame la Présidente
je veux dire au nom du gouvernement mon
émotion et ma
solidarité face à l'horreur des attaque
terroriste qui touche
Israël j'aurai l'occasion de m'exprimer
plus longuement dans un instant mais
dorser déjà et alors que le bilan ne
cesse de
s'alourdir je veux avoir une pensée pour
les victimes
leur famille et leurs
proches j'ai une pensée particulière
pour nos ressortissants décédés leorss
de ces attaques pour ceux dont nous
attendons encore des
nouvelles je veux enfin avoir un mot
pour la Communauté française en Israël
et pour les
franco-israéliens la situation est
éprouvante nous sommes mobilisés nous
sommes avec
eux mesdames et messieurs les députés je
veux le dire sans
ambiguité la France se tient toujours au
côté de la
démocratie rien n'excuse le terrorisme
et la barbarie comme l'a affirmé le
président de la République desès samedi
nous sommes au côté du peuple israélien
dans cette épreuve je vous
remercie merci
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup merci madame la Première
ministre
[Applaudissements]